well I may not be easy to keep employees
happy some employees anyway but a new
list proves that some do it better than
others a mix of companies are laying
claim to the best bosses according to a
new report from glass door Juniper Hays
wrote about the list for Bloomberg and
joins us now so what were the criteria
so the criteria glass doors website
where employees can go on in an honest
anonymously rate their employers the CEO
of the company so the criteria they just
did it over a one-year period and then
compiled all the data you did have to
have at least 100 ratings to make sure
it's not just like 10 employees saying
you did a really good job indeed okay so
who tops the lists so it's not names
that you might expect you know Bain
Capital CEO Bob bed check ultimate
software Scott share McKinsey and
companies Dominique Barton and then you
have names like Mark Zuckerberg at
Facebook and Jeff Weiner at LinkedIn
that were awful one who's number one
Bain and capitals Bob metric okay number
101 yes that's that's bizarre I mean I
didn't even know who the CEO of Bain &
Company was until this list came out
yeah he's not a CEO on the scene is it
to do with how much people are
compensated usually so one of the things
it's not necessarily compensation but
they want a clear mission of what's
going on at the company they want
transparency they don't want you know
uncertainty is my job still gonna be
here in a year like how is my role going
to change within the firm and you see
that a lot with Yahoo they have a lot of
uncertainty and Marissa Mayer was one of
the lowest rated 64% approved of her
this year okay so she dropped off the
list she wasn't on it last year either
she was much higher rated though I think
was in the 80s last year okay so who
else didn't make it onto that list so
some names that were pretty close
Twitter and squares Jack Dorsey was very
close you know he had about an 80 88
percent approval rating at both
companies yeah good
how much does personality have to do
with this I mean I think you want
someone that you know you understanding
can relate to quite a bit and these CEOs
pay a lot of attention to this too I've
talked to people before they'll the HR
department will actually go through this
and see what employees are saying and
then give it to the executive team say
hey these are some of the suggestions
that employers they're doing think of
the staff of your show how to web
like where they could go and rent you
you'd want to see what they were saying
about how you're ready yeah do you think
anybody ever says hey go on Glassdoor
and complete this I want to I want to
win
I'm sure there's companies that you know
encourage that so Duke Madhu CEOs often
go on this list and monitor and I don't
know how often they're going on it but I
guarantee you they're looking at the
list to see where they're ranked and
what their employees are saying about
the companies which I guess exactly
company's doing so this list had mainly
public companies but private companies
are eligible to you just probably have
more employees at a public firm that can
go on and you meet that hundred review
criteria yeah we should say though it
has to be companies that can access so
that website from their company time
you're really passionate about writing
the review or something all right well
it's one it's one metric anyway Julia
thank you so much